معك التحيه يا سمعه
[موسيقى]
ال موسيقي شاب عازف عود وفيانو وصدرت اول
اعماله في الاحتفالات بيوم التاسيس في
العام الماضي وهي اغنيه بعنوان الطموح من
غناء عبد العزيز مانع وايضا كلمات يزيد بن
خالد وهو من مؤسسي فرقه اكاديميه الشاعر
العربي للموسيقى القرني او الملهم التقى
بفنان العرب محمد عبده في العلا بعد
انتهاء حفله له في مسرح مرايا واستمع
المطرب الكبير بنوره على الحان العازف
ودندنه معه ايضا والتقط الصور معا يعمل
عبد الله حاليا على اغنيه خاصه بمدينه
العلا وهو ضيفنا اليوم
[موسيقى]
الليله روحي في الله
يا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا عبد الله انت فنان من اهالي العلا كيف
بتعكس روحه هويه العلا من خلال تلحينك
وتوزيعكم
التاريخي همم الجبال
تحفه فنيه
فحتى اللي مو مبدع بصير ممتع سواء في
العزف او بالتلحين او حتى باي مجالات اخرى
يعني حتى بالتصوير في مصورين يعني بالعلا
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
فقط هذا
البيئه مهمه جدا انت من فتره كنت ترنز
بالفيديو انت وابو نوره فنان
العرب
في حفله محمد عبده في مسرح مرايا
قبل لا يخلص اخر اغنيه للمطار والحمد لله
يعني كنت بالاول المستقبليه
اهتمام بالفنون بشكل كبير جدا
همم يعني ما شاء الله تبارك الله همم نحسد
عليها هنا بالعلم شو رايك نسمع وتطربنا
الى جمعتك اكيد
[موسيقى]